joe biden because he painted a very
clear picture for voters last night
saying
this election is a battle for the soul
of america
the former vice president celebrated
with his wife dr jill biden after
officially accepting the democratic
nomination
to be president in wilmington delaware
they were joined by kamala harris and
her husband douglas imhof
and supporters at a drive-in viewing
party but the main event was biden's
impassioned remarks to the nation
he pledged to unite the country to
overcome what he called
this season of darkness he said love is
more powerful than hate
hope is more powerful than fear light is
more powerful than dark
ed o'keefe is in wilmington ed good
morning
good morning anthony last night just
like so much this year unlike anything
we'd seen before
as you guys mentioned it looked like a
drive-in movie theater outside
and when they liked what they heard they
honked in agreement last night
biden tried to do two things he wanted
to explain how he would take the country
out of this pandemic and economic
downturn
and he wanted to convince americans that
the country can unite
again the current president has cloaked
american darkness for much too long if
you entrust me with the presidency
i will draw on the best of us not the
worst
i'll be an ally of the light not the
darkness
it was a moment joe biden had dreamed of
for nearly 50 years
accepting the democratic party's
nomination for president he vowed
to be a unifier but while i'll be a
democratic candidate
i will be an american president
i'll work hard for those who didn't
support me as hard for them as i did for
those who did vote for me
decency science democracy they're all
on the ballot justice speakers had all
week
biden attacked president trump for his
response to the coronavirus pandemic
just look around it's not this bad in
canada
or europe or japan or almost anywhere
else in the world
and the president keeps telling us the
virus is going to disappear
he keeps waiting for a miracle well i
have news for him
no miracle is coming the more than
24-minute address capped an
extraordinary week
that forced the rethinking of
conventions an american political
tradition
that was produced like never before
outside the building where biden spoke
the campaign invited hundreds to come
watch the speech in a drive-in movie
style setup
capped by fireworks the night included
video tributes from his grandchildren
he likes ice cream in hidden ways yeah
like eating it like in the freezer so
that's like
my grandmother in the freezer and it's
two surviving children hunter and ashley
plus video of the late beau biden at the
democratic convention
eight years ago illinois senator
tammy duckworth who lost both of her
legs while serving in iraq
said biden understands the sacrifices of
military families
and president trump shouldn't be the
commander-in-chief
for another four years they have a
coward
in chief who won't stand up to vladimir
putin read his daily intelligence
briefings or even publicly admonish
adversaries for reportedly putting
bounties on our troops heads
and without joe biden one of the most
powerful moments of the night came from
a speech by 13 year old braden
harrington
who has a stutter like biden i'm just a
regular kid
and in the short amount of time joe
biden made me
more confident about something that's
bothered me my whole life
and at the end of a historic campaign
several of biden's opponents
got together to reminisce you could
think of this sort of like survivor
on the out interviews of all the people
that got voted off the island
[Laughter]
at that's exactly what it was and if
there's anything that should be repeated
again four years from now it's a reunion
of the vanquished opponents
as for biden and harris they now hit the
campaign trail but they're expected to
do so mostly virtually
aids say there are currently no plans
for them to visit any battleground
states
and that the pandemic will dictate the
travel schedule
tony all right ed no one's voting you
off the island thanks for a great week
and we'll see you next week get some
sleep this weekend good thing